bella a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono con il signor
gatto e oggi giochiamo ad un gioco
particolarmente conosciuto che ai
blocchi trap land avevo giocato tante
volte un gioco reichlin tipo che mario o
super meat boy solo che si gioca online
ma questo è il 2 primo mondo vediamo se
funziona si allora ecco lì è partito
malissimo lesivi e ghiaccio ecco qua non
si vede niente perché io sono in aspetti
perché è morto due scudetti effetti devo
cambiarla videocamere ecco questo è il
primo livello si abbia è veramente l'ho
capito però lei mi fa vada vada questo è
il primo livello lo fanno anche i
bambini venga qua qua c'è una ram a
faccia attenzione però la salt ibra mi
sembrava che comparisse dalle il primo
livello signor gatto e analizzata siamo
stanno succedendo cose racconta anche le
morti
non volevo sapere a chi bello no è lì
perché mentre non c'era l'altra volta
bene il gioco a livello 2 livello 29 nov
i salti in testa perché se non vogliamo
ci sono e allora cos'è una sfida ci sono
2 mm ma è lei quello ma dobbiamo avere
di qua no non ci sono più e lei allora
il marchio l'avete se ne frega mar
cavalca sono morto
c'erano delle spine attenzione faccia
attenzione e non le avevo viste per un
tasto per saltare in avanti
accovacciarsi che però non userò mai
dopo fatta bravo ma basta che ce la
faccia che uno vivi vinca bing ma allora
il genere quando arriverò alla fine
aspetterò che lei faccia non si
preoccupi c'è una puzzola dov'è
eccone l'effetto attenzione fa secondo
me ci ammazza qui nota come la puzza
l'attenzione qua che ci sono le noi
siamo gatti siringano di noi
ho fatto arrivare le frecce venga giù
occhio bravo attenzione venga farà
sempre e solo dato che soltanto sono
morto no no no no che lei è morto
non me lo dire grazie però grazie utile
benissimo gli ha fatto saltare di sopra
vede che c'è un modo come un altro
lavoro da fare che invece adesso davvero
no ma no stop su luca però aspetti come
si fa il perché è rotto a visso no
neanch'io all'esca passati la arrivo
porca vacca io spero di non morire
perché qua un casinò dove devo andare in
altri e forse di per sé già allora il
ministro in due forze perché venga
pochino lei entra a dice che colposo ma
neanche quello che aveva da madama
ma signor gatto la prego mi distrae mi
dice non basta sono forti forse l'ha
fatta è una pavia va da via pignolo
l'aspetto bhangra per tutto venga su
salti venga con la colla bravissimo a
questo sui tempi ho vinto mi ha messo
una vita da lì che catino può riguardare
morte ha poi diventano a pedara
mitraglietta di morti 32 morti va
simpatico grazie avercelo ricordato
fendi o comunque colpisce un bug che
vedo più personaggi prova niente
l'odio il sasso io sono vivo e bravo
anche a direi bravo a evitare i sassi è
andato così ognuno il suo che sia
assolutamente in da qua
come si fa ok mattel super meat boy
effetti che tanti auguri grazie a ce
l'ho fatta c'era c'era ce l'ho fatta
vado a volte perché pure di ucciderla
alto da sicuri che sia giusto così ma
basta fare questo ciao ce l'abbiamo
fatta
non l'ho uccisa io mi scusi il mio
momento di quattro i casi non è così da
tutto proprio mi piace come è successo è
bello di questo gioco si può ammazzare
senza volerlo allora guardi guardi dal
maestro ma ve lo vedo col cappello lei
ma gli passai muller ho mai però è solo
un sito avranno sul passo dell unci
bassolino però mi piace che ci sono più
modi per arrivare ad un gusto nella
nostra per me è il modo è uno solo che
ti fa credere che ce ne siano tanti
perché stronzo il gioco
bravo ma lei ma lei è mai quindi vada
vada vada prima lei che poi questo è un
gioco che rispecchia soli suo nome è per
questo che sono bravo certo era un
dettaglio mita trascurabile si parte dal
basso
no dai l'avevo detto
occhio che il sogno della tribuna da
padova dove fa una parte sola va bene va
bene ci stiamo aiutando systrom a cenate
sopra c'è un tasto perché appunto
e così è successo è arrivato un p
ragiona aia grazie l'avevo detto
l'ha tirato fuori lei arrivo
marino eccomi qua ma facciamo un attimo
ma lei ha rischiato di uccidermi non va
dal non guarda non vada ma mi lasci
finire ma edizione uno si fa il mazzo
ogni livello sforna più me no
[Musica]
si tolga e come faccio adesso non mi
salti addosso la prego
ecco no non è stata una motosega poi
vabbè non mi mette in mezzo attenzione
ma signor gatto aveva lei ma non livello
neanche quello niente eh vabbè terrore
che errore mio e lo fa stavo scherzando
bravissimo come a falck ma fin qua non
era il problema era qui a le alette e le
riprese a mezz'aria di molto bravi e
sapendo cosa può succedere fa niente
quali che sguardo che c'è l'accattivante
non ne manca uno e abbiamo finito il del
bonus c'era tensione sai che c'è un
bonus di dove siamo adesso so il
trapasso a questa puzzona nella vita
però visto che lo dobbiamo inseguire
abbiamo fatto e sono morto ma non aveva
mica visto che quello di era pericoloso
guardi è un boss ma bellissimo ma
veramente se dietro non sono morto
chiedo scusa la colpa mia
dobbiamo fargli rompere qualche ora il
bravo ha detto che faccia spaccare siamo
morti signor gatto non fa niente ma
faccia spacca ecco bravo facciamo
stradali ok gli spari sparando per
colpire il cervelletto cervelletto vado
non c'è un gruppo in una volta è ma io
vivo il tempismo ci vado cpc sposi
eccolo quasi quasi sono morti senza
questo arrivo è la madonna e ricchi
signor gatto di click
ho cliccato bravo a questo è morto dai è
morto penso di sì soffitto tra de conti
salgo sul pugno molto bene smash
nell'ennesima share e perché era scorsi
ha aperto guardi è aperto vado è stato
fantastico una paura ma va bene anche
carino costruisce la boss fight ogni
finale va bene mi è piaciuto ragazzi
vediamo il prossimo livello bello per
cui la puzzola sempre più personaggi mi
stavano all'inizio però va bene ma va ma
non fu ok perfetto o sono riuscito
grazie guardi guardi il gatto bravissimo
va in gara vi provi provi
e noi che quale sono fregato fifty fifty
ct bravissimo lo vede si poteva vabbé
non importa allora guardia ci sia questo
tipo che è passato certo senso venga
venga e non ci riesco
yes no ma la samale sappiamo big mama
mia la tempesta di sabbia mi spinge
verso sinistra orribile orecchia vacca
ha fregato nori vie signor gatto venga e
qui c'è il milan timori ma clutch e lo
fa aveva allora faccia faccio
e quello lì è proprio gli spazi
imbattibile scolastici si parla ma tutte
di tutto lì adesso la vedo la vedo
spedita di susie su di qua love ad areva
da lei ma sa che non so dove a c'è un
tasto associati c'è l'ascensore denti ha
spinto i miei compagni che non capisco
il senso
ma perché spi l'ascensore salaria deve
fare così
oplà ok e poi di qua fatto no direi non
si trova ci provo
mamma mia se ci ho creduto no no ma non
è difficile semplicemente non anche di
non ci sono soldi doc è ovvio che mamma
mia ragazzi se livello difficile avere
oltre lì si pensava di andare ancora
oltre le spine ma oltre non ma forse
così si è guardata e problema adesso
mamma mia ma guardate guardava da propri
la moto si è riuscito non ci crede sarà
difficile mercaldo 4 pari ma sono
fissato nei reds sono esploso dobbiamo
fare po perché fuori il primissimo che
mi esce perché facciamo un po a caldo
non ho capito
fa caldo e come milano in questi giorni
non ha capito da corra che fa fuoco
ok ci sono
ma bravo bravo va bene mi piace a lei a
occhio che fanno curare sotto attenzione
guardi qua prova fare questa non guardi
me guardi il suo personaggio da fermo il
bottone che servito il bottone ho aperto
un segreto vada vada al segreto o via
bing va dal segreto no il segreto ci
arriva prima lei provi il ed andare il
segreto così in basso è quello in basso
esattamente qui sotto vada ok il
sinistra che segreto è non avevo capito
mi rifaccio lo riapro parola capito poi
proprio si entra lì così una manina
vabbè la butta via quello di niente
piaci schiaccino a posto sto già
schiacciato ma sono scemo io a questo
gioco lo odio signor gatto cambiava
davanti per padova vada che un carro non
si può mai fare niente di diverso
è difficile ed i ragazzi spero che il
video di oggi vi sia piaciuto interrompo
qua perché io signor gatto stiamo per
sclerare ancora tantissimo visto che è
un gioco fatto apposta per far perdere
neuroni però signor gatto mi sembra
contento noi ci vediamo proseguito
iscrivetevi schiacciate la campanella
così vi arrivano le notifiche di quando
metto video discrete il canale signor
gatto e ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vinto
bari
[Musica]